oh my god eric tay we are going to
stream dark souls 3 right now we're
gonna do it it's been a long day we've
gone through the gauntlet but we've been
privileged enough to allow we're allowed
to show you the first hour um from
character creation why not so let's just
get into it we're gonna do it yep
uh yeah great brightness who cares uh
more settings my bad
i think there's an intro here
if there is we're gonna shut up indeed
it is called lothric
where the transitory lands of the lords
of cinder converge
in venturing north
the pilgrims discover the truth of the
old words
the fire fades
and the lords go without drones
when the link of fire is threatened
the bell tolls
unearthing the old lords of cinder from
their graves
aldridge
saint of the deep
the abyss watchers
and the reclusive lord of the profaned
capital
the giant
only in truth
the lords will abandon their thrones
and
the unkindled will rise
nameless accursed undead
unfit even to be cinder
and so it is
that ash
seeketh embers
all right i think this is where i do
character
solo or
kind of like character select or
character creation that's right they've
given us a variety to choose from so
first things first
name
got my name uh i will play a male that's
fine um this is the more important one
we can go old
i want to go old
all the way all the way oh man ty's
going to hate this gameplay down the
road
all right here is it's kind of like
where we diverge on the path here knight
is pretty standard right you played a
little this before are you gonna
continue with your character or try
somebody new um i can't continue on my
character we're only allowed to show the
first hour apparently and i don't know
why it's not switching the
character screen thing
well that's right it should show the
different
view of them
he's changing the stats
i wonder if it's because we're on max
settings
i played a mercenary last night it's uh
you can dual wield cemetars
i'm not sure why it's not changing it
though
no it should be changing warrior is kind
of like uh i don't want to call him a
viking or she a viking but uses an axe
i think harold is a spear
thief daggers uh anyways i gotta pick
something
and randy told me to play something i
haven't played and
mike has played warrior he played the
warrior i played the sorcerer and we
have footage of a
thief so oh god i don't want to really
use spells because i play melee so
screw it play warrior well you're so
boring though it's like
it's what mike's been playing too right
so we we have footage of it
uh
restorative miracle
am i gonna heal myself you think i'm
gonna heal myself with fp
no i don't know if i like speakers
though
what's up guys thanks for joining us if
you're just tuning in now eric and i are
going to be playing the first hour of
dark souls 3. we're in the process of
picking our character then we're going
to get into it
yeah this always ends up taking longer
than you'd like it too
i'm so sorry
basically we are only allowed to show up
to a certain point
so we're just going to keep going and
investigate as much as we can until we
get to an area where they tell us to
stop it
i am checking chat if you guys have
questions eric and i have both played
the game
i don't know how many hours have you
played i played about four hours total i
played around the same because i played
some of the beta and then some last
night i picked mercenary because i did
play some last night it'll be a little
bit familiar which will help
of course uh this is something you just
get off the bat
and i'm not sure what i'm gonna take
here um
the ring's not bad because it just gives
you hp free hp
and
so let's just do that safety first i
guess i turned up our mics oh cool
mentioned that uh let me know i am
listening i'm looking at your
looking at the questions
these are supposed to change to the
faces death count prediction oh yeah
that's good that's good i should have
put a death counter in there i could
have done it i'll i'll verbally count
32. i don't know why these aren't
changing
they're supposed to that's a little
weird uh if we have to
we'll see what happens i mean the uh
intro screen played fine
yeah so that's a little weird um but
yeah i agree the
visuals should be completely changing
right now i should be ripped uh-oh
what do you think we should do i mean we
can restart the game if if it plays
funny but
i mean at the end of the day we can just
get into it and hope that the gameplay
plays fine all right
fine we just won't do the character
creator thing that sucks i guess
she's kind of unfortunate
it's kind of fun you can make like
purple
smurf you can make them real messed up
oh that's good okay
oh you know why no they're we're hooked
up
i tested it that's awkward
you run through it real quick i'm pretty
sure
well we could always go offline but then
that's not good because that's not gonna
that's not gonna save me
i don't have internet then
and she tested oh i'm loud to myself hi
hi
you know definitely not the game's fault
this is something on our end
um
i'm being prevented from playing a fun
game called dark souls
this is called login souls
i mean the only thing i can do is back
out of this thing but i we'd have to go
to the camera shot
need more ethernet is correct
um it is very weird
because hi guys um i'm going to exit out
of the game and we're gonna try to get
back in
it's weird though
we are
no we're still okay
i think
okay google works
so that's that's all good
i'm gonna log in and out of steam
did you get
an issue with your internet before
because you were on steam just fine
right yeah i did go i did set myself as
offline but that's not like
anything um crazy crazy
also i did that last night and play fine
nope i can't connect the steam
okay
i could always go offline mode and then
we just don't save my character which is
also fine
uh because it doesn't really matter to
be honest
which is probably what i should have did
in the first place
uh yeah
assuming
okay
yeah i am getting internet it could be
steam
um because you know i was able to
like i can go to
yeah totally internet's mine maybe it's
steam i don't know we'll try offline
mode see if that works
looks like we are having some issues
with connecting
to steam we're going to proceed ahead
anyway
and uh just play the game in offline
mode and just not save the character
that's all right can you do me a
wonderful favor yo can you turn us down
on the headphones
i can't hear us yeah no worries
okay let's try
this in offline mode
what was that
steam is down sick okay so even if steam
is down i think we can still play an
offline so let's just try we'll attempt
to play in offline mode all right one
second here we go
loading
all right there there i am
i think
god willing
a mercenary rising up out of his grave
all right messing with our mics if we're
too loud too quiet let us know i'm
messing with it right now
here we go
sure i should look like an old buff dude
uh tarkus asked if we weren't worried
about the embargo uh the embargo does
remain we have an exclusive for the
first hour so we are allowed to stream
the first hour correct we have been
given the okay
no one else the a-okay
do i want to fool around here
get them hot backstabs yeah let's do it
do it on the easy guys for now
before i can't do it anymore
here we go no problem all right we got a
fp flask which is always good that's for
like sword sword arts and or weapon art
sorry i keep calling them sword arts
because the sword arts aren't online but
they're definitely weapon arts
so i can dual wield these cemetars
that's what makes the mercenary the
mercenary at least to start you can
definitely
what do you know about the frame rate
um so this should be 60.
this is on max settings on a
alienware that has three nine seventies
i think
so it should be pretty good
uh this guy's just sleeping
while his buddy over here is gonna try
to stabory nose
hey i'm over here buddy
uh i'll show you
uh
weapon art in a second
there are some items somewhere um maybe
you guys don't care about that though
and you just wanna see combat but you
know
so
continuing on
uh i forget it oh there is totally
something here to the right hopefully
let's let's not get rip counter number
one here
hopefully
um i don't scrub it up and i one shot
this guy
i one shot him last night but like
barely so
anything could happen
here we go here's messing with the
stream bit right right now give me a
second oh yeah stream bit rate
i'll mess around with the stream dog or
just the ice dog
oh that's not so high
so estes up here
i didn't expect i thought he was gonna
roll so that's on me
nothing like having to stream this
oh no staminas stop spamming spammies
okay
i'm rolling like too much
kind of used to like
bloodborne ish
i did not mean to backfill like that
okay
slow and steady wins the race right guys
i try to use some of my left hand
attacks with the right hand here
this is an interesting guy because he's
kind of like a secret one-ended boss
like he he's just hanging out you i
think you don't even really get anything
out of him he's just kind of like the
first guy you encounter but there's no
other person like him he's just like the
only guy hidden by himself he gives you
a titantanic shard i think
oh no
that was so greedy
okay well this is going to be like last
night where i have the sweaties
and
oh good good old whifferoos
uh so the reason we're having problems
is because we're streaming at 60 frames
on like
oh that maxed out settings so our stream
pcs oh god
still
working on that give me one second
i'm still working on him and he's about
to kill me
don't die i died
rip counter number one
beautiful i went all magic when i played
the demo for three hours and he got me
the first time too but no like that
that's the worst that's the worst though
like you one shot him the night before
and then you tell the stream that you
can one shot him and then you uh you do
it no
apparently not
no problem though we'll just run back
over to him burn through it yeah well
see that's the that's the deceptive
thing yeah exactly start wanting to rush
through it i've done that multiple times
even last night where i was running back
to a boss
and
by running back to the boss i'm like
okay i just want to get back into the
boss
and by doing so
many mistakes yeah i end up taking all
this damage because i'm going so fast
and blah blah blah you know so
just always got to be careful about that
kind of stuff all right we should be in
business now all right so they didn't
see that first step right
no they probably it's all good no it's
not yeah i guess it is it's gonna have
to be i know right
give me my souls back
i would go for them first he's waiting
for you
yeah i'll get it later
this is a
ice roly-poly move
okay so he does aoe oh my god the range
of my scimitars
oh hello
i think i can stagger him nope super get
greedy
i got i had just enough stams to run
you know
uh but this game is
without a doubt faster
uh
than we've seen in previous dark souls
games you're saying before you're
getting way more of a bloodborne vibe
from it uh
i would say the movement is
definitely faster the bosses are faster
they're expecting you to move more
even with
my shield i found myself dodging way
more than just using a standard
shield and sword
yeah
it's definitely faster i do miss my
bloodborne like
um
which one called like dash through
because i use that a lot
and i'm getting used to more of the the
the dodge rolling there is an
invincibility of course i just gotta
time it um but
i haven't been doing a good job
if i just hug his ass do you know uh
specs of the pc
uh i don't know the whoa where are you
going bro i need you over here
i don't know the processor oh
crap
i don't know the processor but it's got
three 970s i believe
it might be wrong maybe the alienware
there's the beast machine i wish i
i should know that kind of stuff
but you know instead i'm here struggling
with
ice shard dude
okay so far
looking better but i don't want to jinx
myself
come on do that do that stupid move
not that one
okay
my heart is starting to
uh you know
[ __ ]
pick up uh you know in heartbeats
don't want to rip again
do you find that i will even be using a
shield
most likely not come on i'm just gonna
drink this flask because you know just
dual wield yeah i'm gonna try to dual
wield most of it
or um
two hand
you finish him finish him
no no
that's how you die man
that's how you win no that's how you die
all right so you got the titanic scale
yeah get my souls back also there's
another item over here
oh okay those are just some souls
feeling okay now i can
breathe a little breathe a little bit i
was
holding my breath
didn't want to die again death counter
is at one
hopefully we don't hit double digits
it's pot it's definitely gonna happen
though probably
uh tarkis was saying uh that it looks
like
um
the bosses might have had the
difficulties turned back up i know some
people were saying that they've been
altering the difficulty of the bosses
and various uh
enemies and that's true when we played
it before
um i played a demo
for a couple hours all the bosses were
in different locations and they all had
different hp so i mean like same moves
but they were without a doubt they were
they were changing them up so
even if you've seen footage
from some of our previews
it doesn't really reflect the final
product they've been moving things
around so that we're surprised so that
things are different yeah hopefully if
um
i don't scrub it up too hard we'll see
some of the stuff that was
um in beta like it's the area after this
more or less um but there is definitely
some stuff here to do that's right we'll
go to the central hub first of all
that's right around the corner basically
um after we get through some of these
dudes and a boss
oh that's right
which most people have seen i believe
that's the first boss that looks like a
a knight he's got a giant pike
yeah but did he i'm gonna ask you
something when it actually happens
because i don't necessarily recall
seeing it
but um
their transformation yeah transformation
was always was it there okay because i
didn't watch too much of the stuff
beforehand tried not to try not to spoil
it i swear like to me that felt more uh
bloodborne as well like these halfway
transformations seem to be almost
expected they're doing it a lot more
which is great because it
it changes up
the gameplay extensively right you can't
just get adjusted to how to attack a
boss
a lot of times in this game we found
well so far in the first four bosses
they
change either themselves
or the environment changes in such a way
that you have to change up your tactics
to take them out i still haven't figured
out how to get that dang it
like
you can't i don't know if you can drop
down from there but i can't roll off
from nice secrets still on that spot
this must be a dude i guess i killed
that dude um there's one more spot for
stuff
i don't know if it's worth it but we'll
go down there and get it anyways because
i don't know i'm like that i guess with
rpgs i just tend to
this one's a little sketch though
it's a pretty narrow spot della borga
asked if this is the official this is
the
final build pc version pc version that
you are seeing this should
should be it unless they
you know
pending like a patch you know this is it
oh he gotcha
can i take this boss with two esses
flasks
yeah oh you want to rest again i don't
know sometimes like it's right there but
then i want don't want to all right you
know what we're just gonna try to fight
them and then do it we'll hope for the
best you know because
actually it's yeah you're going to need
one right before you go through there
yeah you're on half i agree
good call all right
okay here we go so this is the first
boss i think he has a little bit of an
animation if he does i'm going to turn
up the gameplay so you guys can hear him
i don't think it's um like a cut scene i
just think it's a small animation
give me that coiled sword sir give me
give me give me man you just start like
get those free hits in gotta get those
free hits now run
okay that felt early i thought he was
doing the overhead
he's got range because of his stupid
weapon
he usually does a second okay
now attack his butt
oh
oh he's doing the shoulder charge he's
not having it
okay do the dance
ah
oh too early okay
got lucky
oh that's the show
slam pajama
still got one left
no it's okay it's weird because i
haven't figured out why he does that uh
spinning like backwards attack it's part
of the moveset of the cemeter's i think
um i should probably learn why that's
the case
uh but
i think it has probably has to do with
directional pads that i'm hitting as i'm
attacking oh [ __ ] he's gonna go
transform all right so this is ludex
grunder's
transformation at half health
he's a bastard get out of there oh my
god okay
this is it for you
do it go ham
oh my god tay
no
okay
you're a beast beast mode yeah who knows
about pixel life baby now you got turn
around
as most dark souls people do nobody
thought i would live that i didn't think
i would live through that that was
amazing all right
now that's an inch so the interesting
thing there is ember just restored there
is
um so you're like now you're like i'm
like rekindled and you saw how like i
gained life that's right when you die
you uh lose like the rekindled this is
the same mechanic as previous dark souls
but now it has a different
name for it
instead of losing your humanity
you lose your
kindle
and so right now you can see tay's got
some hot embers coming off of him that's
because he
just got his number restored every time
you kill a boss
or every time you use an ember
you
regain your max health
correct and you get that until you know
until you die again
but man does it suck when you die
because it's
it's kind of like this juggling act of
do i use an ember
uh do i not you do find them in the
world but it's not
necessarily something you farm it could
be used as a last resort so like if you
burn through all your estus flasks but
you got your boss pretty low you could
use an ember in order to finish them off
yeah you know they don't come back so
that's a
that's a personal decision there's one
thing i do have to check on that note is
just that if you're already um
like rekindled i do not know if you can
use an ember on top of that
but maybe
i've never i've i personally have never
like because in the beta i didn't have
the ember and i didn't use one last
night because i was just being trying to
save them on top of a kindle yeah so
like i died right but i never used an
ember but like let's say i'm already
rekindled right now i don't know if i
can actually use an ember
on top of you know oh just to reuse your
health yeah yeah i see what you're
saying
oh god
yeah there's an item there but uh
yeah
it's gonna be fine
you are too slow
okay let me pick up that item there's a
couple items here to pick up and then
we're going to get to the first like the
hub world that's right yeah this is like
you know the new majula well they've had
them in uh
yeah it's like the the dream world in
bloodborne um i think they had it yeah
like you said i think majula as well
manjula was like a giant area it was a
town this is you know
yeah i guess it's like your one-stop
shop because it's not like that's right
it's more like a demon souls yeah okay
i'm not fighting that guy because i'll
show you him later after i spend my
souls last night i made the mistake of
fighting going after first uh should i
just go in there now instead of pick up
the items all right fine we don't have
to pick up all the items going in and um
level up your character a little bit um
there's also i mean as expected there's
the traditional things um shop tube yeah
upgrade your weapons yeah got a blast
from the past in here too right
that's right
we'll see him in a second welcome to the
bonfire unkindled one what's up what's
up
i attend to the flame
and tend to thee
the lords have left their thrones
and must be delivered to them
to this end i am at thy side
level be up
she reminds me a lot of the doll from
bloodborne
but i mean i guess that's just kind of
how it is
well you are uh
you're like our bloodborne man actually
so you're not a big fan you haven't been
playing the dark souls series but you
got really into blood
bloodborne that's correct so this is
kind of a
different side of it i'm
kind of used to maybe more of like the
speedy
still pretty good it's just i got to
personally get used to the roll
i'm going to do the scary newbie thing
which is a go
all vicar
almost all like well actually no you
know what i'm getting diminishing
returns that's 30. that's only oh it's
about 35.
uh you know there's probably soft caps
like most other dark souls games um i
think same with bloodborne where like
you know you start getting diminishing
returns right well you can always um if
you're looking for more damage to you go
to the blacksmith and you infuse your
weapons or
you get some really hot items in the
next world
so
providing you can survive long enough
you end up finding items that are better
anyway that that really up your damage
speaking of the blacksmith why don't we
go
check out the blacksmith you guys might
remember this dude come back to her in a
second a blast from the
a past i see
i am andre i serve at this shrine
as a humble smith
forging weapons
you're in search of the lords of cinder
i trust
a toilsome journey i wager
you'll require good arms
let me smith your weapons
i am a smith
such as my purpose
uh andre if i had the materials
and the uh souls to do it i would
totally take you up on your offer
um
so there's different gems
i think one of the starting items you
could have had was a fire gem which i
didn't take i took the ring which gave
me more hp
um but yeah you'll find these in the
world sometimes on just like random mobs
and whatnot and these are like you said
will
like increase your damage um you know
with the raw gem physical damage and i
think the first one which is to
reinforce it
um which is
i don't have the titanic shots but that
would also give me damage so there's
stuff you can do to increase the damage
of your weapons and whatnot and so yeah
i don't have any oh wait you know what
you can also do uh here you can change
your estes flasks so if you go more
magic
like i did i was putting them all
into my magic flask that way i could
deal more magic
but for you someone who's
doesn't require any of that you're gonna
you're gonna put it all in uh life yeah
i'll i'll show the sort uh the cheese
but yeah it's weapon arts i keep calling
it sword arts but it's weapon arts i'll
show that in a second i said i was gonna
do it earlier and i didn't so that's my
fault
another one it's not a dark souls game
without a depressed soldier
well you're not alone
we unkindled are worthless
can't even die right
gives me connections
and it have us seek the lords of cinder
and return them to their moulding
thrones
but we are talking true legends with the
metal to loot the fire
we're not fit to lick their boots
all right got a new
hot emote
collapse why don't you test one out just
make sure yeah which i need to switch it
to get that hot collapse
i'm so depressed
uh there's another dude i could talk to
but so the funny part is there's the
sales guy as well for items oh right
okay so we can totally go check you can
scope him out is there a her or is it a
heat i find that was a dude
oh okay i just thought it was a
feminine man
which you can make in this game because
like let's be fair that's a very
gender ambiguous clothed person the
interesting thing is that the hair
is like unisex in this game
so i had a female and i gave her like a
faux hawk but then she also had some
like hair that was very similar to the
ffx or ff15 yeah main character i was
like oh i can make that
guy as i want
no
nothing like creepy laugh
all right so
she sells different things obviously
um at the cost of souls
this is the same as it always was um
you know arrows things that are
expendable
um and then some items but we're pretty
poor right now uh you spend it all
leveling up but you know there's a key
of course that you're going to need at
some point you can buy spells oh you
could uh heal yourself that's pretty
good
yeah the spiel the heel scrolls are
really nice
if you go with a magic build
so pro tip oh i uh that took me about
five to ten minutes to figure out yeah
actually
um
me and ninety percent of the people at
the demo did not know what to do here
yeah i was okay yeah so totally right i
was
running around like this whole the
firelink shrine thinking okay i'm
supposed to go up here somewhere out
there and then it's like i never figured
it out and then it was like oh
i'm supposed to drop that sword here
anyways i'm gonna try to fight that one
dude oh outside outside yeah now that
you've uh got a fireplace to yeah and
nice to be born
go for it i am afraid though
so there's like embers out here but
i'll let you guys find that all right i
cheesed this guy yesterday uh-huh um i
don't know if i'm going to be able to do
it again but if i can it'll be pretty
funny although i'm kind of like i'm
rekindled so it's
probably not
worth
dying this guy this guy's a stud though
he's got freaking katana and he freaking
bossed me around last night let's see if
oh
he's so fast
is that four attacks in a row yes
garbage
where's your stamina man like
you and i can do that oh my god
nice
is that a weapon art the spinning
spinning yeah was the weapon the spinny
spinny look how much damage i did that
was like four hits and weapons alright
saw that
but it did stun him a little bit so he
didn't get a hit in uh which
gives it more value
oh god
hey this is a pretty good oh
those stairs saved your buns you can
also press just b to backpedal which is
interesting i didn't
i'm the master here
oh he's back
you can um
the ultimate cheese is pushing off the
edge i tried that but i'm so scared to
fall off and then lose my kindle
oh
got a piece watch out
get out of there
what a dodge
oh god okay okay everyone stay calm
i had something going really well for me
oh geez i know he's wicked fast oh god
oh he buried me
stay down boy
stay down
that is
uh where it ripped to rip two
he did not do that last night uh dude
they look really good though i mean i
know that's embarrassing but they look
holy [ __ ] when you backstab someone it
looks so nice they've done a great job
with the animations
that sucks now i lost my kindle
awesome
see how much life i lost out of that
we're on the road
to rip 50. wow e tay
he said that
we said 50. that's that's pretty
generous
more like 100.
oh god
that guy like auto tracks which is kind
of bs in my opinion but
they take forever to shoot though i mean
and they're easy to dodge
yeah well that is true when you're like
looking only at them you knew he was
gonna be there come on yeah but i got
stabbed by the spear
who's got those sweaty palms right now
only i do not you
palms are sweaty mom's spaghetti
all right get him i'm gonna try to knock
you off come on sir get that little
speedy demon
nice
i was just
if you time it right your
sword uh weapon art you're breaking it
uh also it's stunning him you're
stunning his yeah you're stopping his
attack which is really
all you need to do here because he just
keeps attacking oh thanks man this is a
big
speedy dude all right
oh we're going for it
yeah see you later buddy did you do it
sayonara
oh you know what though
all right you know what we got to do so
you do get the item from doing that it
still works the same way like old souls
and bloodborne and all that stuff um but
i think i have to go to a bonfire and
then come back okay
so i'm gonna go do that real quick then
we'll go to the next area
um even though there's some secrets and
stuff left
but we'll go do that hold on
i also got oh i just got an ember from
searching for stuff but uh let's switch
to the shield i think it's better but
i'm never gonna use it
to be honest
uh there's like
there's like a dog
if you don't use your shield you might
as well like pick the lightest one
possible yeah that's actually a good
point i you know what that's another
thing i have to
kind of um
get myself to do worry about weight was
never really ever worried about weight
have to be worried about weight in this
game there's a stat for it it depends on
your build you know
um yeah but mike like your build yeah
uh
oh yeah so we're gonna go grab his
katana which is pretty cool i like it
it's got low durability but it's fun to
use so we'll grab that and then we'll go
quickly to the uh new area
i know we said uh
the first hour but what we mean is
there's an area that takes about an hour
to get to
yeah i guess so right like i know kind
of where i'm not allowed to show yeah
we're gonna stream up until that ish
area
because we had some
a few issues
let's check out the stats damn it i
forgot to pump one strength
you know what i might have enough to go
pump one strength to make it um
you know you never want oh right um yeah
so you can't use that weapon yet we'll
go do that his armor is actually worse
than mine it's it's kind of like what he
it's kind of what he was wearing uh
earlier which is like rags
that's well i'm technically wearing rags
too i guess yeah but that dude was
wearing like a loincloth yeah he he was
a true champion
so we'll get you
one plus strength so you can
use your katana
and then we're gonna go and then we'll
move to the next area let's do it
run faster
oh crap
forgot to talk to the lady i know
it's like bonfire you can do the same
thing right okay what you're saying
i'll touch the darkness in you okay i
don't know that's what she said okay
it's not my fault if she says it i know
i know what she said
if it's in the game it's like she's soft
lobbying me something like you know like
what am i supposed to do okay so for
anyone that
needs to understand this like
um
you need to use
the bonfires to like travel around now
so
yeah so this is instead of one giant
world which is actually kind of how i i
always really enjoyed it but they're
you're using the bonfire to get to new
areas but they are very uh
circular in nature so the level design
does loop in within itself
uh much like in previous souls games
where you'll unlock a door and it kind
of leads around as a quick pathway back
to the beginning so they still have that
intricate level design but to get to the
separate
areas you now use you use the bonfires
okay this should be fine now to use
so the katana is just like one hands
like this two hands like how he was
using it
um i forgot what the sword art is on
this guy but
no you you are required to use the
bonfires in this game you can't have a
i mean you can't avoid it um yeah i mean
like to get to uh like certain
areas sometimes but there are also times
where you know there's still the level
design of you know shortcuts and whatnot
which if i can get there we'll check out
a shortcut maybe
if i can get there all right this is
very reminiscent of the beta or the beta
um
yeah this is what probably if you
watched footage of it you probably saw
it from this area but
they've moved enemies around uh the boss
has completely
moved around
there's a nice backstab
they do such a good job making it feel
impacty
you're innocent but give me your souls
i think there's another dude you should
roll away
watch out behind you
there's that guy and then there's
another guy from the stairs coming up
sometimes you underestimate these guys
because uh they're kind of weak but then
they do
do some crazy uh some pretty
well you need to worry about are the
knights
they're coming up a little bit
i hate those actually then the sword
night is okay the guy i have problems
with is the spear knight um there's
dudes up there too
yeah but it's not i don't think it
progresses you in any way well there
wasn't the beta here yeah yeah yeah um
yeah there's but see they all kind of
jump on you at once so it's
oh who threw the fire
oh there's a guy above sick
where are you sir
oh
mistakes were made
cower
all right who wants to come down the
steps
we are not fighting on your terms
you will come to me that's not how this
game works
all right so watch they're still
throwing fire yeah you think he can get
me from here
i'm always surprised at the angles they
get though so oh
i can cheese you too
i think so
oh yeah that's right
i think yes there are weapon arts uh we
used them a little bit
uh tay when you kill this dude either
use weapon arts or afterwards let's show
off the different weapon uh
weapon arts for this character
so it's not character specific as much
as it is weapon specific um
binoculars
okay so let me
what does that even do oh is that a
parry is his weapon is the katana's
weapon art oh god all right thanks mary
well it's gonna be easy now we know
now we know it's gonna be easy weapon
hold on you get a good item i got a
steel helmet
it's nicer looks like it's all right
yeah
because that matches the rest of what
i'm wearing yeah that looks hot that's
great am i slower because of it though
does it match your rags
they're like
they're so weight like i said weight
does matter and it'll affect your dodge
and i think it's affecting my dodge
like
sorry kill that innocent yeah he still
gives souls
i don't know it
hard to say it doesn't feel exactly the
same but
all right so am i supposed to try to do
this weapon art is that what's happening
yeah just show it real fast
it's a parry though like if i don't land
the parry it's not gonna give you
bring it okay okay
believe
believe it
come on
nope miss timed it okay miss timed it
again sure did
there we go that would have been a
frontal freaking uh thing
front stab watch out all right you could
probably get
a backstab but these guys are pretty
slow
i can backstab him all day cause i can't
get this weapon art where am i supposed
to like hold it down
what does that do what is what does this
do
oh
there okay so i have to okay
okay so i have to swing after that's my
fault like with the other weapon it
would just do it you know what i mean
like when i hit a left trigger it would
just do the the weapon but with this one
it's like a charge okay fine right and
you can see that it did work because
your bar went down
which replenishes uh at the bonfires or
i don't know if this is going to go
through
i believe oh watch it he has three
attacks yeah
i just i just want to do that
damn it all right we gotta get behind
him i think there's oh hello
i don't think this is gonna work the way
we want it to
yep
all right no problem
i'm gonna get it off maybe not on this
guy though
that guy's kind of tough
oh i heard it i heard the all right
we're just gonna so go up there we're
gonna have someone else do the work to
get the dragon to come down and then
he'll
bring hell on those dudes
oh he came down you did
she went too far
i wanted to show you guys the fire but
i'm pretty sure you guys have seen the
fire yeah everyone's seen this area in
fact
honestly
nice backstab
you probably want to just
don't rush it but we'll kind of like go
through here so that we can get to any
to the new area after that thanks mary
you just rush through it just get
through all right all right i'm gonna
try hold on we need we need our friend
up here to like
hey
hey
oh
so take out that guy and then if you
walk just a little bit forward he'll
he'll rain fire down there
sir
dragon
my friend it'll happen
i feel like you're lying to me no it'll
happen
i feel like i've been fibbed too because
i think you guys are running after you
now but
he's doing it right now is he though
yeah
you can run through there okay do you
think it was too late though no but i
would run
i am holding it down
now the knights up ahead so watch out
yeah so no estes flasks you can avoid
him though i could
like you can he comes but he comes he
comes down here though yeah he comes
from the right
okay there's a dude on your left there's
a bunch of dudes on the left here
okay so if you hide i think he doesn't
see you
i'm a solid snake
where's my box that guy's a real son of
a [ __ ] i know he is
i totally agree with you on that on that
note okay
um
oh he saw you saw you
no problem mary no problem i wanted to
have this fight anyways oh my god
no problem this is the way we wanted it
this is how dark souls goes goes
i hate when
or we can
oh you running
if you run upstairs there's a bonfire
mommy
mommy
i know you're here
we've all done this oh why won't you lie
because there's an enemy by it
a little thief don't let him take you
out okay you've come too far oh
he's he's a crafty one though
oh
okay oh god
not like this
not like these mirrors
oh
not like these
nothing like these
okay
that was good ah
sometimes you gotta know when to run
folks
damn there's a thief almost got you
there's no shame in running no rip
counter okay no no
needed rip counter
um so should i be going like faster
through this mary do you want me to not
no no no i mean go through it uh but i'm
saying like we don't want to go through
every nook and cranny because we've done
it in the previews
so
we'll just kind of
get towards the boss but like by all
means
the the gooches
i've been calling him the gooch pooch
yes what is what's his actual name
fort
um i call him that because he's a dog
like an ice dog and he's really like a
bailey
he's on all fours
and you only attack his butt like that's
the only safe zone that's fair do we do
this guy do we you can do the roof dude
he's pretty tough i think well there's
there's a there's a trick to that right
is um
or at least it makes it a little bit
easier but it's not a lot easier
okay
okay all right no you're here
fall down see you later all right
where's this other dude
we got the drop
boom shakalaka
yeah we're gonna i mean
depending on how much you guys have
already seen of this game we're trying
to give away spoilers here um
this is all stuff you've seen in the
beta we'll go past this to the next
level afterwards but i don't think we'll
be going past that
stay away from me so you won't be seeing
past like the tree boss or anything no
he's almost dead already oh god
oh god
just burns
jesus that's supposed to make it easier
it did you saved your life let's be real
here it wasn't that much easier saved
your life so you want to kill that guy
though because you get a titanic shard
and an ember which is pretty good
um fire bombs for sure though to make it
easier i scrubbed it up these are kind
of like those
kills you get him
oh no no kenna reminds me oh no no in
diablo um treasure goblins treasure
goblins run around
get him he's so fast
okay
give me my raw gem you [ __ ]
uh skittered away from me
jeez all right
um
i mean okay i can try to get to thing to
dude
um
[ __ ] this this this part do you want to
two-hand that weapon or do you like it
two-handed if they want to see it i'm
not a huge fan of it but we can do it
for you not using the other hand anyway
oh i got lucky real talk
oh i'm gonna stamina
no that would have hit with one hand
gotta kill this guy
okay
i normally don't take this path i go uh
i just fall off the roof and take a
little bit of health damage there um
yeah definitely a shortcut um i just did
it because i hate that archer guy but
yeah you did it out of spite you did it
you're correct uh i would normally go
that way too which is you could fall off
the roof i think there's an item there
too but uh if you go down here
like i have dropped down from where
you're talking about
you just gotta roll at the right time to
not take ball
you
damage
i'm so stupid
areas of the level where you can see
this balcony and you can see them
hanging which is sweet because then you
know in the future
they'd be waiting for you i do marry do
i oh you can run past him i know
i've done it before but there's embers
over there and stuff
don't mind me sir
oh he saw it you don't see me john cena
he saw you no he didn't no he just can't
leave his area okay so this is an area
that's a shortcut so if you go up here
there's an uh elevator that takes you
back up to the start of this area
i'm gonna grab that actually i think so
that we can uh in case we that way you
can struggle with the boss yeah we can
easily get back here
seems like a pretty good thing to do oh
people are asking um if we're gonna end
in an hour i mean we're gonna keep going
obviously what we meant was
the first hour of dark souls that you
can get to
um but we kind of took our time in the
beginning we also had some tech issues
so we're just gonna keep going um i know
when we're supposed to stop oh do you
okay so we can just kind of keep going
to a degree okay
have some webinars yeah we'll just keep
playing oh the camera ruined my weapon
arts mary i totally did it too well it
still happens i know that's true all
right so here's a
mr shortcut
um again because i played more
bloodborne than soul stuff this is very
uh
you know pretty typical for me open the
door that's right now you're
now you got your shortcut yeah now i'm
going back down though
i think i think we can
we can take oh you know what we got a
flashback from like killing something i
think
which is cool are you gonna take on the
boss now yeah i actually just
dot i just jumped through all these
dudes yeah i did too once you figure it
out yeah once you figure out who you can
run by you wait for the knights to kind
of patrol and then you just hook it
depending on what preview coverage you
guys saw there was this woman who like
dripped from the ceiling i'm not sure if
it was a lady
right yeah
the frigid lady
she was to the left here and to the left
she's not there anymore
now you go to the right
for the gooch pooch
i have that arpg thing though like
diablo where i feel like i always have
to
kind of
kill what i see but here we go
how many rips please guess how many rips
on this boss
uh
will there be ripperinos
i hope not
i'm gonna turn this up
he doesn't really do anything crazy
rip headphone users
all right wart let's board it up
yeah so this guy is all about now he
also has two modes
um so in the first one
he does these long sweeping attacks like
you just see there and as long as you
stay under his
butt like right there
you're pretty good
um he doesn't really like that's kind of
the technique for this this guy
but he mixes it up halfway through his
life you'll see that pretty soon
and then you can't do that anymore
here he goes
um he has a grab move and if he grabs
you i mean you're pretty much done for
her
interesting he never did the grab on
me it was just too fast oh thanks
sweep
and then you go in for the butt step
he's gonna do like
i don't even know if i have to do that
second roll there but i feel like okay
he's changing right i think he's
converting
um oh lord so that's what he becomes he
does i think three dashes in a row
oh lord and then he does this frigid
move
if you get caught in that
there you go
i was gonna normally i run around and do
damage to him but i wanted to
you're almost tough
watch out yeah
gotta be careful oh god that was a throw
i think maybe
you are
oops don't get greedy tay yeah sorry oh
that's it story of my life you know
rip number one
i did not ex uh show the patience there
what is that rip three rip three rip
three i could have killed him though i
had two more flasks
i kind of like ah why are we here i
could teleport i just run over there
it's fine it's fine no big deal you use
the
you just fall right here you can fall
it just takes the snidge of your life
yeah but you can every snidge is a
snidge mary
can't be snitching tuna
one snidge too many you could say
well i'm going to eat a lot of damage
here i think
on the fall there's a little roof
to the left
uh there
so if you fall oh god okay good you
pushed it a little bit and then if you
roll right as you fall you don't take
anything yeah
it's a it's a precarious i just spam it
technique oh that's a and then uh
sometimes you're like yeah that's a
technique too yeah okay so you wait for
oh someone's shooting me that's fine
yeah that was the guy on the stairs but
no no problem no problem no problem yeah
so we'll go after this this dude again
but i mean i'll tell you the first time
i came across this boss
i think it took me an hour because your
magic right i was a magic build and it
takes
it takes
a good amount of time
to get the daggers out
i mean they're not that slow but they're
slower than your average maneuver so
was
do you wanna get your souls i have
anxiety like oh god
see it wasn't worth it
you say that maybe you lose your souls
like that little back pedal oh this
fist
oh that's cheap
don't mind me i'm just gonna hide in his
crotch most of the time here i think
what broke me about when i did it was i
kept getting him down to about a third
of the life consistently but i couldn't
kill him because when he converted into
the speed mode
i could never hit him because he was too
fast i can hit him really well during
now he has all these breaks but
all right he's half
he's got another one
all right
you're at half-life
uses his frigid move
okay greedy
oh
i think he does
one more there he goes
this is really greedy yeah well
yup okay
nope did we learn what do we learn
to be greedy
i just want to kill him
i had so much stamina to run away too
this is like
dark souls life
this is
i don't know it's almost like i
have anxiety from watching
you do what i did for
yeah it's like
i did that i went through this whole
thing where i kept getting him to like a
third and then i died
i mean for an hour
and you know these things are like you
get really
okay
it wears you down
oh you're gonna take more that's one
i think that's why i thought we talked
about smidges yeah i know
but now i'm in like just get to the boss
mode
which is not necessarily where you want
to
be mentally but somebody asked about
firebombs i think
maybe it just takes a while to wind them
up and really if i'm if i just played
even remotely smarter like he would have
been dead right in his second phase yeah
like
you want the you want your speed attacks
and you want to just play super
defensively i think tay's just kind of
going for gold here
you can kind of see why you call him the
gooch pooch right like yeah like i don't
even see the front of them like ever
got your butt gotcha gotcha
butt
you don't think he looks like a dog
don't use your fast moves here i'm going
to drink while i'm in your
underbelly
it's the safest place there's no safer
place with this boss
he's gonna he's gonna do his dash here
he goes
he's got two more
all right
now he's doing his fridge
this is when you sprinterino and just
like ah
ah
weapon art
oh he hit me
all right let's stop going too yolo here
don't
go too yolo he's going around
oh why does that hit me
oh
rip five
did you see that though did you see that
hitbox it's like he hit through his two
back legs it's really wide you gotta
like
okay no you know what that was my fault
you gotta really stay
under
under that belly
i don't need a repair yet it's mine um
okay
i had like three flasks there or two
flasks left i think oh it's really dumb
sad times
all right
i'm gonna go into
full concentration mode okay i almost
missed the ladder
as i say that it's very concentrated
nothing more concentrated than fall
around ah that hurt quite a little you
forget you don't give me your roles
trying i'm trying to do right you
concentrate you concentrate no i uh i
didn't do what i said to do which is a
spam
spam role i've been trying to actually
time it and i clearly don't have the
time for it it's fine yeah when i so
when i finally killed this boss i
did you stand up and go
i got a drink oh did you yeah
um
was it alcoholic yep nice
soothing i made myself a whiskey
he's
i think he's harder than the tree boss
like he's
well i guess it depends on the character
that you play but he's fast yeah
definitely
get that butt
all right canceling [ __ ] oh
and it also
stuns you i'm running into his face now
it knocks you back
all right
going too crazy here
not even sure what totally happens when
you get frostbitten because
never been fully frostbitten but
definitely doing a poor
right now
get that sam back
all right here comes the charge arenas
oh i got so lucky
jesus
get behind him oh no i think i can get
behind him here okay
so why do you prefer one-handed over
two-handed
because of the how it swings i guess
just my preference of the
oh pledge me
all right
because i don't know it's like swing
radius i just preference
swings faster i guess
nice dodge
bad time
blast it's fine
i mean we can try two-handing
probably gonna rip because of it though
oh
i can't play the way you want that's
fine
oh he killed me i did he found you in
the corner hmm rip six lipsticks
no that was really bad i should i should
get out of there to fly
no problem
um yeah i don't know like
so when you i don't know i mean it's a
personal preference and
uh
when i was doing my magic build i had a
small shield and okay uh
my wand in the right
but it affects your
weapon arts so it's
yeah
i mean you can definitely also i could
also dual wield the uh scimitar and
are faster
yeah but they do less damage they do
less damage so it's like a trade-off
right
again why i uh i've been going
one-handed
a lot of people are asking for the
comparisons of bloodborne
um it's like the middle ground right
it's
slower than bloodbornes faster than
previous dark souls
um and
of course the biggest difference to be
on well there's two big differences at
least for me
for those that play bloodborne and
whatnot is that you have ss flasks
instead of vials which you could just
free farm vials you can't necessarily do
that in this game
you have embers but you can't spam those
and then there's no regain system in
this game like there was in bloodborne
right so in bloodborne i could get some
life back if he hit me right which is oh
god that's right if you you were
rewarded for being
aggressive yeah essentially
which that isn't really the way in this
dark souls is more
and they're staying true to this which
is it's more about learning the patterns
of your enemy
and using that
to your benefit but they really did take
some from bloodborne in the speed
i think the visual style has definitely
been inspired by bloodborne and you're
gonna see that in the next area once
this boss
goes down the next area i mean they're
it's uh you know you have like what are
they like the pitchfork farmers and
stuff that look straight out of
bloodborne
all right he's already in his second
form
so this is a great run
he's about to do his
frigid breath get a few hits in
um there's already lots of secrets
hidden throughout every corner you
definitely get rewarded for going down
dark alleys
oh lord
he's gonna charge freaking die
okay right don't charge me bro
truce yikes
okay
that was close
one more
should be doing his breath
that's my fault rip seven yep
uh pro tip just don't panic roll like i
just did there you can you can always
perfect timing you always panic towards
the end i don't mean you i mean no in
general
all humans ever that play this game when
you get them down to about a fifth
health your hand starts shaking and you
freak out and you say i got it i got it
i got it i got it and you don't got it
totally had that that was that was so
botched especially since i had one more
flask
you always say that like this is the run
and then like oh i didn't even get my
souls back that one time but i don't
really care right now i didn't have that
much to begin with
oh what's what's so funny
am i getting trolled
oh yeah
yeah get good that's the nature of the
beast
probably pro tip is get good eric get
good yeah you're right that's what i
would say too i agree internet i agree
ah damn it
uh whatever
oh man
okay
big dude's following me that guy's kind
of a pain in the butt you can kind of
stagger him if you kind of get diamonds
right but i mean we could spend all day
in this area alone oh yeah um there's
all sorts of secrets oh that's
unfortunate
mental start
ever fine it's fine i'm not even getting
any soldiers because i died that doesn't
matter don't worry about it
we can do this a really slow way i mean
i can play safe if i want to but it's
like
oh
there you go with your gut
i tried
i swear towards the end of my hour i
swear i spent an hour on this boss i
tried every tactic under the sun even as
a magic build i think i started uh i
equipped like a
sword
just to see
i was doing it wrong i like couldn't
copy it you get him
get him
don't get greedy
he's got another one
who's
i'll let my stamina go back up so i'm
not doing
all right he's running yep he's got two
one
their ice breath
breath
all right going for the kill yeah we
should be able to get him here
in it got him to win it okay nice job ty
yeah sorry guys that took longer than no
no no no no
that's not bad it was i could have did
that the whole time he did that's all
that matters it was
um
oh you need to get the flag from the
other area to progress
sick um so you know let's just rest
rest up rest
your bones my weary feet so
if you go to the other side where the
old boss used to be you'll get a flag
there that
you oh what a beautiful
just wanted to come for the scenery you
know what beard no expense
i have no banner to be raised all right
let's go get that banner
i just wanted the glory shot you know
you get it in fact man okay this next
area is
really beautiful like the cut scene to
get there all right so i got it but
there's three nights in your way okay
you can cheese them you don't have to
fight them you can sprint past them
we'll see how it goes what do you what
do you what do you think i mean i did it
that's what i did
i gave the finger to everything in this
world once i was able to get away
like
you're not having any of the the beta
test i couldn't give a [ __ ] i want to go
to the next area but i mean it's up to
you you know your play style like you
know
you want 100
go for it
mentality of like
i probably don't want to and you know i
get punished for that right because
because i don't
check every area i don't find all the
secrets i typically lose items that
other people tell me they found really
cool stuff and i miss it but
deserters armor there's a
you did all right so i think there's
yeah there's totally three it's the same
as the beta yeah there's this there's
that guy there's one ahead of your guy
and then there's the guy to the right oh
there's a guy to the right too oh it's
there yeah but you won't um
you won't
if i run through there they don't follow
me
if you run through there you're going to
aggro at least two of them
so how does that work you just sprint
man you just sprint no but i thought
we were getting something though yeah
you got to get the banner oh they won't
go through oh they won't go through the
doorway all right
but then we gotta run past him that's
right you gotta run past them twice you
know what
fight like a man baby oh my god
you gotta try like a man i'm so
impressed
don't be impressed yet i'm not you
shouldn't be
shouldn't be impressed by anything that
i do oh god
they have so many moves they've
five i think
okay i'm not afraid of this guy it's the
the other guy that
worries me quite a bit
nope you got me
you can afford it i can afford it
i got him okay so that guy like that guy
has never been really a problem for me
it's this freaking spear guy
that i have no answer to because this
shield is bigger
i i just want to confirm the chat some
of them are talking about that this is
running at 60. uh it should be it's on
max i haven't turned anything down
this is running at max settings on 60
yes but then i don't know if the stream
i don't know if the stream is doing all
that though if it's pumping out what it
needs to be you know right if there is
any
stopping it it might be
actually held back from the stream
itself
oh
i hate you i hate you so much
the pike oh he tried to hit me with this
yeah he's like no no you can still
sprint past him this is still an option
all right no i'm a man all right sort of
oh
what a man okay i'm not a man all right
i'm a half of a man okay now i'm a man i
got a pot okay
oh my god um
you trying to cheese him against that
wall
maybe don't do the charge move okay okay
no
oh he fell
boom chocolata
gotcha no
oh i got you i got you i got your legs
oh that was impressive
uh which one do we want
that's right
all right let's hi stream you are
sorry sorry sorry sorry amazing all
right go get your banner go get your
banner you got to do some rp all right
all right
there's definitely items and stuff
though for sure yeah uh but the further
you venture there are more nights to the
right i know there are yeah i know you
are absolutely correct so this is where
that uh skinny lady did drip down from
the ceiling before
but she ain't there now who did lady hey
girl hey
the wait has been long and kindled one
i am emma high priestess of lothric
castle
allow me to speak frankly
you will not find the lords of cinder
here they have left gone
to their churning homes converging at
the base of this castle
head to the bottom of the high wall
for john through the great gate and
raise this banner to proceed
okay i'll raise your banner
um all right we're gonna try
all right two hand
at some requests yeah it's
okay do we wanna fight this guy then
oh he's different i'm pretty sure he's
different he's got the blue cape you can
go to the new area and then do it in the
new area let's just do that that way we
can start showing you guys new stuff
that we haven't shown you from the beta
because we've kind of run this area
ragged i've seen this area for hours is
that one guy still downstairs that
secret dude remember the one you killed
oh yeah the uh there was like a
different ice guy that frost night or
something um he was
you know what i didn't try to go get him
okay the area the area is definitely
there um but you know you'd have to get
the key and whatnot so
all right so raise your banner and this
should trigger a cutscene and i'm going
to raise the gameplay audio and enjoy
the views because it's
beautiful here we go
oh
so that is the new way to travel to this
new area called the undead settlement
you are carried by
little demon birds
are you sure we can show this one i
don't know i thought so i thought we
could show this area
but no boss
oh
you want to check the task
we're going to double check i don't want
to get in troubs
either
all right i'm going to okay you know
what we'll do while we're confirming
that
i'm gonna go level up
because you can do that now
but yeah i'll try to
try to level up some stuff here
uh we can we can also blacksmith let's
go blacksmith first before leveling up
um
so you guys can see what that's like
get some damage on
well
you guys rather see the katana or the
scimitars health
what needs smithing this day
um what did you guys what did you guys
prefer the katana or the cemetars
see
the undead section is where we are
supposed to stop so we can still go back
i guess or we can call it um i'm going
to i'm going to fast travel uh you can
upgrade some of your weapons
and we could
show off anything else people have
questions about and answer some
questions before we end it
we're not allowed to show off too much
of the undead
section
um until
our embargo lifts that's tomorrow right
tomorrow at eight um more people will
stream i think we if we're gonna stream
it might be at 11 uh but i'm gonna
infuse this
uchi katana with a raw gem that we found
from one of the bosses i believe it's
gonna increase the damage to 149 let's
do that since people said katana
can we say anything about invasions i
don't know if we know anything that
unique about invasions at this point
besides the fact that you can do it yeah
i currently don't know more but
there is potential that that could be
something that might be brought up
tomorrow i'm not sure we haven't
confirmed that stream so i don't want to
make it i know at the demo event that i
went to
they
said that we could jump into each
other's games to help each other with
bosses but we weren't allowed to record
it which is interesting so obviously
that's
something you can do
but we weren't allowed to get video
proof of it
i think a lot of that is just because
they haven't like
insured the servers yet for sure just
making sure there's no weird stuff
happening
all right um
bigger it is
because i'm scared
i'm gonna go kill some stuff while
there's some stuff being talked about
well
oops
why don't you confirm on that mary i'm
gonna go back double confirming to
um
let's go back to
perhaps
vort and we'll kill some knights or
something there is definitely some items
that we can pick up i think
i want to say there's like a rapier
somewhere as well that we could um maybe
i can find i don't remember if i got it
off a random mob or a uh it was in like
in a corner or something
but uh
those dudes are back great
hey that's me mary i'm just kidding
all righty let's do some weapon arts i
keep wanting to say sword arts can't
help it
come on come at me let me do the bushido
move you gotta open up though bro okay
all right the archer is not having it
pretty quick it's a circle straight this
guy
screw your arrow
that's matrix right there
oh that was that was dirty
okay he blocked my um
he blocked my weapon art
you're pissing me off
uh weapon art killed him in one hit
though that's pretty cool
right trigger does a
it's kind of like a uppercut slash
so we're just checking on the um
that one area yeah we're just making
sure we're allowed to do this yep
so we're gonna keep playing and then if
we can show some of that area i will
definitely go in there and show it yeah
i'd love to show you guys um i'm being
told two different things uh who's the
guy playing that's eric tay is playing
i'm mary kish
you guys are watching the first hour of
dark souls 3 the final game on pc
at max settings 60 frames
this is not a demo this is the final
game
wow the reach is real from this guy
okay my right trigger's too slow
he tried to do a sword art or a weapon
on me
damn oh lothric night helm
hello
yeah do i have any i got some other new
gear right guys
like a deserter armor that's not somehow
not better did you upgrade any of your
items yet i upgraded my sword
did you infuse it uh yeah i think i used
a raw gem i didn't actually have enough
shards i think to uh
to like upgrade upgrade it to do like
two upgrades rather
oh damn it
the surprise attack we had him damn it
i gotta be careful
all right it looks like we can show the
undead settlement but we can't show
me rolling around so much
yeah
oh that was a decent trade i guess i'll
take it it looks like we can't show like
any bosses and we can't go down there's
a elevator going down and we can't go
okay all right i will do that right
after i
kill that dude kill that dude first
oh
all right all right
oh pillages corpse oh and ember maybe
you can form them i think you guys gotta
get lucky though all right so amina if
you guys have other questions we'll
stream for i would say probably like
another half an hour half hour and then
we'll kill it um so
get those questions in should i just
i should just teleport there huh
or is that slower can we raise the
banner again
well we've shown a few bosses
these we'll put those up
in the post there was
vort
um and then the first boss that's really
the only two actual bosses i've done
i've done
like that one
semi mini boss in the beginning ish and
then there was um
who was that other and then we fought
that weird the weird transforming dude
which um he's kind of a pain when you
let him transform
all right we're going to the undead
settlement um i've never been here so
this is going to be rip city i can give
you
it's okay a little bit of help we can we
can rip for the stream
everyone loves watching people rip right
okay
okay
oh that guy's like an old hunters dude
over there you're gonna see so much
stuff
from
what you visually would consider
bloodborne like the
the whole uh
i don't even know what you'd call them
villagers it looks just it looks very
similar okay you can see
yep
um oh how come what
open sesame is that the secret yep
there's a little area to the left though
that you should see first uh okay
all right
uh
we're i'm being told to go left we're
going left
yeah i know you guys probably want to
see it all but the left ends so check
that out first and then check out the
right roger that
oh i hear you
i hear i hear it i hear
what are you guys eating
oh an allering skull is this guy okay
this guy looks like he these guys look
like they're alive
i don't know what to do
you can't lock on them
okay no these um not to spoil it but
there's no dangers here yeah you can go
through although it does look scary as
hell doesn't it's an item
uh i believe
one of these dudes to the right
is still kicking
sir
are you
oh
please grant me death
undo my shackles
am i supposed to kill him
he said undo my shackles oh
no
oh then it's true a champion of ash as i
live and breathe
to be in your presence is a great honor
i am joel of londor a pilgrim as you can
see only
somehow i failed to die as was ordained
well perhaps my calling lies elsewhere
say
champion of ash
how does the idea of taking me into your
service strike you
i was once a sorcerer
surely i can be of use i like this guy
he seems to oh i um what if i decline
him all right
be of service
i am honored truly
i should be dead
yet you have granted me purpose anew
i
yolo of londo do solemnly swear myself
to you
alfred i'm gonna call him alfred where
did he go
yeah that's pretty good pretty good shot
there all right
off to yard i mean off to the undead
settlement
all right got some like witcher [ __ ]
going on up here yeah a little creepy a
little foreboding
frozen
why why i want to be your friends no
there's no friends here there's a
bonfire there you have no friends here
i feel like it's trap
there's no trap you're safe
don't kill me
don't you can't kill someone to suspend
that's the whole point all right
it's a trap oh no
all right so you go through that
old witch house over there
yeah see and tell me these don't look
like bloodborne dudes
oh he died in one what the guy in one
swing you got a little pitchfork
the old yharnam oh wow the roll freaking
staggered him
what you got a worker hat
i think a worker had to better than my
hat
probably not
nope
definitely not
had to see what it looked like though
farmer's hat right
okay
oh look it's groot
i am
i know i i hit them just because anxiety
you stay dead
why can't i have to hit you to get the
item
what about that guy no they just got
light on him that's cool
oh no
yeah
no
not these guys i think mike might have
spoiled that for
no
these little cage demons no you saw that
in the trailer they gave me the oh crap
where's this guy
those guys are really fast and they're
meaner than you think they are just uh i
you know um you want to die no no no no
no
i want to uh i wish i had my bloodborne
lantern right now so i could see
what the f is going on well you ain't
playing bloodborne
i'm not that's true
i think there's a couple down there too
okay they're kind of like dogs
i know they're terrible oh i just can't
right out of my room it's okay stay down
they're stupid little witch hats yeah
how do you even see out of that bad cat
kind of fine whatever they use their
senses
okay okay we're okay a little dark
charcoal pine bundle oh i think that's
like paper
okay you can trust nothing i don't i you
never trust
the the world of the souls games
oh i gotta chop that guy and chop him
down and then you gotta go down to get
it do you think this
please don't okay
oh hello
i can't see he hit me that's that's
trash
you're trash and
physics
physics
sorry
oh where'd he go well you
you upset the balance repair powder
that's always good
it's worth getting hit for i guess
break those pots yeah you can't waste
your weapon uh
durability you gotta
do a barrel roll
yeah it looks so cool when you remember
yeah i know i never want to lose it
no you're going to lose it how dare you
oh god
okay okay
okay
i'm spamming a lock-on for okay
can i do the the leaping attack
do you hear that
i swear here like fly
we definitely heard something it might
have been this gentleman no hear it it
sounds like buzzing
oh i hate it
are any of you
going to attack me
oh god
mary i'm anxiety yeah it's super hot
okay all right it's going well
okay we're okay right we're okay here we
go
didn't even phase him
not a fire is normal for these these
these folks not an inch
i should have okay this is not that's
not an oil barrel though i don't think i
don't know we'll find out
got it i went from like
throwing it like well to just throwing
it terribly all right forget it
oh
see
it's not so bad how do their friends not
even care they're worshiping look see
they're they're worshiping this tree
um so they're in the zone but see that
fat dude that's in the front of the
dream i've seen her well for him that i
don't so if i attack another gender
ambigui if i attack them will they
actually like all come at me or will it
be like the same
situation they all come at ya okay well
[ __ ] it
yeah
you lied to me they didn't they totally
oh well not in that sense like once you
attack them they're gonna come at you
what differentiates my granada
or firebomb
this
another now they're aggroed
why are you what are you oh so the thing
that it shoots at you which i think is
on her next
bible verse no no it is a projectile
that even if you dodge it it will come
back for you
yeah
l-o-s-b-i right so actually you did the
perfect thing right there which is you
have to get it to hit something in front
of you or to oh that laugh
oh it's horrible it'll continue to
circle you
oh my god
i have no stamina
oh
sorry
[ __ ] stay down
damn backstabs they're so hot stay down
stay there go over there in that corner
so much of it you you get out of this
level yeah
you're gonna push it off the edge i want
to push it off the wedge do it yeah
watch it don't don't make a mistake ah
forget it
close enough
all right he died as he lived this is
butt in the air
so are these guys free then it seems
like they're free
um
you too
nice
what was that i don't know if that was
like this delay
yeah i see it's like slight hiccup and
oh
my name is scarecrow
i just wanted some courage
that's the that's a lion ah whatever
yeah what did he want a brain a brain
see he needed the brain
no just
just just know just if you don't get the
reference don't use it you can't all
right internet okay you haven't seen a
lot of
musicals let's just move on i watched
the oz okay
are you talking about the tv show about
the people in prison
oh sorry wicked
that's what i meant wicked you have no
idea no wicked you're out of your
element
how dare you
how dare you
hey i'm in somewhat in my element here
we've only had seven rips that's not
terrible it's not great but
not terrible
all right oh where did the patrol come
from
why are you patrolling
weapon hearts
i got some worker gloves those are
probably useless oh that guy aggroed me
from that far away
i saw you running
hey girl
ambiguous again
yeah i'm not sure why didn't that work
that's the dark souls way honestly you
never know what gender it is and it
doesn't give it doesn't matter because
they're both
horrible horrible
versions of whatever that gender is okay
there's left side here
hello
anybody home
i'd like to talk to you about the lord
our savior
oh no
it's so dark nothing good can come from
in here
oh it's moving
it's just here let me help you
oh there's a little item in there
see the little item it's a freaking
narrow hallway too
i feel like i shouldn't be doing that i
feel like there's oh
trying to trap me
legs
oh he's got a lot of health
oh my god
he taking no damage gross
don't laugh
dude he's taking 17 damage
are you serious
we've got a cage okay at least at least
they don't do very much
oh god i thought that one was gonna be
i don't i don't know if this is the
right way to go mary yep gotta go down
oh god okay
let me free you what do you have
okay
okay oh no there's so many more
so many more that one's alive okay so
this is one tell cause they're different
colors colors
ooh
also hitbox
any items no all right all right
is there more than one of you you vile
leg
cage
this didn't work last time but
they didn't really hurt though not that
i should take damage from that they're
just meant to
mess with you mentally because it's
disgusting
red eyes red eyes
black dragon
for all the yu-gi-oh fans out there
so many
okay
i'm so feeling safe oh no
you know what
oh wait there's going to be something
that's come from above honestly i have
okay
yeah i've had that parts world for me
little
go to hell
give me stamina
you have no stamina you put everything
in vitality this is your bed lie in it
it was only going to be one more stamina
when i when i look at it
i know that's the point so that the
stream won't see too many more
ripperino's because i have so much hp's
that
i'm going the new grout
this is a veteran veteran move i like to
think know
i don't think anyone in the stream can
can fault me for that
that wind up is pretty slow though five
fading souls
more fading souls
okay
always be looking at the corners
okay
is that oh she shot that shiznitz
i think it oh no too slow
dude how am i supposed to avoid that
that's some garbage right there the
black
projectiles come in this way yeah yeah
so you have to get them to hit something
in front of you even if you dodge them
they circle around and come back after
you
so you just got to get them to like hit
a wall nothing or use a shield which you
don't have i have a shield i just
haven't equipped
hey come this way let's have a chat in
my office my airbnb
see that's so weird that like
me like at the combo
that was a
right bumper and the right trigger in
the right trigger
where is my next loss point
i hear a lot of noises
i am afraid oh what's this
oh yeah oh yeah
accidental oh i wonder if you can flank
can you flank her from the side no i
don't think i can climb up that
oh wow it's still coming this way
i heard it i heard a splat
that's a nice little
secret am i supposed to do there yolo
you only live once all right okay fine
well yolo after this one misses because
she can't cast two right
oh what
what the crap is that all right all
right you only live once see it's gonna
oh
my oh you son of a there's two of them
oh yeah hitbox and i got a whippy whip
got this weep
they got you with the old item
yeah but it was what i had where i had
to go i think
i don't think this is the right spot
nope it's okay
i hate the noises
this isn't the right spot either
oh don't make that noise yeah you're on
your own i haven't been this far
i like some more
stop making those noises
freaking me out
oh do i really have to climb oh
that is horse doo doo
if i've ever seen it oh no
nice
that was some garbage merry that that
[ __ ] is bricks those are stone it's
cobble
she's really fast oh no
go
oh
it's gonna turn on fire soon i think
oh god
oh damn it
i wanted to
all backstab power the old backer
stabbers nice
i'm just gonna get you so satisfying
what
i don't i don't understand what that was
but she's dead hey you you're a real son
of a bee
i hate you all right
i have one flask mary where is the next
bonfire
where is it oh
you can jump through
no this is how they get you
that's a tree you can get through it
through the house that's a tarp
no you can't there's no way to get
through it through the house look at
that and then you got to go down there
and get that dude but then what's up
here oh oh you know what there's
definitely something up this ladder so
let's go do that
sorry i'm totally like
oh we got to investigate but you got to
get the loot goblin as well i know
i know
what you got for me oh that's good
that's for upgradies
i don't want to lose my ember either
all right we're doing it you're going
for it we're doing it all right please
what if i miss this like you're gonna
make it
i'm going to make it honey get it
no it's a trap there was no it's so a
trap
invaded by something
mad dark what is why you were invaded
who is that it's probably a developer of
the game because we went too far no
don't police
do you see that i didn't even get that
item that mary was so sure i was gonna
get well i
was assuming perfect don't be a real son
of a bee right now right now it's not
coming after you
no no no no no
no no
i'm running
is he falling i don't know we're about
to feel like we're getting sniped
oh he's following i see him i see his
little pink body isn't it hey
bro
come on come on it's come on come on
come on you should max health right now
come on though
oh my god what's the plan i don't know i
don't even know what he's using
he wants to fight you
i don't want to fight well
he wants to find you
yeah
that didn't even hurt him well
yahty
you sir
are a piece of crap a piece of [ __ ]
i'd rather die a real person i'd rather
die to an npc no go get him no i can't
kill him did you see how much uh this
guy's
equally as bad
um
are you looking for a
a
bonfire if you keep running you're going
to run into some problems i know but
maybe now that guy will have to oh what
was that
what the [ __ ] was that
oh there's these freaking things coming
they're spears yeah
where are these from that tall dude oh
you son of a oh they're still coming i
guess you got to keep moving
just keep moving
no
not like these
run
there's guys in my way
no
no no no no no
i'm just gonna aggro more guys i feel
like yes that's what's happened already
though okay well at least we're getting
an item
oh i got hey it was totally worth it we
got the cleric set
yolo set 420
lmlg no scopes go
oh he knew i was gonna run into the
house
oh there's a red-eyes black dragon
it's time to
do
where's that guy in the piece i don't
know how do we successfully get rid of
him i have no idea
i am so scared
i am so scared
stream
oh
please
please let there
please god
let there be a bonfire somewhere in this
this territory
so that oh no i definitely can't go
that's the tree boss
oh oh
shortcut this is a shortcut shortcut
okay at least we got that going for us
maybe there's a bonfire
that would be nice oh check what that
warning is
cursed ridden tree ahead no wait
is this the way of the tree boss no the
other side was definitely a tree boss
okay that's definitely all right oh
where's the bonfire there's a bonfire
homer boned this [ __ ] right now
oh no how do i do this with no
flasks
oh my god let me see your shadow
go back up to the edge
yeah let's see that
it's actually pretty detailed
remember in destiny i've pixelated the
shading no but i can't lose this like
kindled i know this is not your focus
they're coming after you no what do i do
you can run past them yeah but where the
hell is the bonfire that's a dog
dogs are fast
all right they've
yellow emoji 420. love it
you got it
remember the
oh
butts
420.
all right cool yeah but there's still
dogs on the right yeah i know about the
dogs
what's to the right maybe we're just
okay maybe this looks good this looks
sacred maybe
no
no okay what's that kill that
up the stirs i'm so scared wait what's
to the right
to the left or the right uh both but you
killed that mama majulas over there
that's what i'm just going to call her
uh
we definitely don't want to go back
there that that place sucked
that was that was not cool there's a
bonfire
hidden in here somewhere oh that's a
that's a dude that is a dude that's a
hard dude right there where's the bomb
there's multiple dudes
where's the bonfire though
you have to make a call it's either up
here or we go
straight forward
but there's so many things that will
kill me both ways
this is the worst
you don't know where you don't know
where the next bonfire is i don't
i would tell you if i did but i never
made it this far in the demo
but see i'll have to kill her and him
and i don't see oh what's over there
there's oh that's a boss too or
something
all right i don't know if it's that way
because that looks like a dead end
you just never know
okay
something palms sweaty summon the
courage i guess you can still we run by
this guy like run by them all right
that's what i would do
oh why do you have a jar a giant
jug of death where where is safe
what is even safe do i run for the other
one
please please please please no
no no no
okay we came here for the item the
caduceus ranch i don't know if that's
how you pronounce it
the caduceus the caduceus the caduce oh
he left me alone
oh there's two there's like three guys
up there
you can't throw that far
oh god all right all right uh are we
running by this guy again then
how does he keep getting i don't know
pots i he has one big pot that's his
weapon of choice he harvests with it
but he also i'm a pot farmer oh
i think he's following you watch for the
dogs oh good call good call i don't want
to have to deal with that right now
okay okay oh
did you
go go over there consequences we'll just
no no no no
there's there's got to be a bonfire
around here there's just no way that
like you can get near a boss like that
and then not have a freaking bonfire
like oh
oh but see are the spears going to come
out again
i feel like they are
yup oh that guy just ate the [ __ ]
good
yeah but three three
oh okay this is just scared
listen
there's god you're probably gonna die
but that's okay no no it's not okay it's
not okay
this game is all about
can i get there
oh i took fall damage you sure did
you know don't you can't try it again
you can't afford to
are you up on fire candle you're done
i'm not done so i could homeward bone
what i'm laughing oh my god do i go out
there
this is not a demo this is the full game
on pc running at max settings 60 frames
uh
oh god i'm in a house
we're
testing out the first hour oh lord oh
you're a sniper with huge look at that
that could have killed me then he gets
i'll look out the window maybe i'll look
out the window he's gonna spear you
i don't know where to go don't spare me
i honestly don't like it wasn't the
other way and like we didn't see any
bonfires over there besides that orb
that's
that's how you died
rip it
wow
what a freaking map hacker
that was
some map hacking if i've ever seen one
that was some
that was mlg no scope 420 right there
some [ __ ]
oh the spears are
i don't oh my god that is so dumb spears
are
no joke i think you just gotta keep
keep mobile during that area
i think again wasn't there a section in
bloodborne that was constantly throwing
[ __ ] from the uh sky and you had to keep
moving in order to avoid it yeah it was
a hunter that had a gatling gun that's
right but you could get that guy to roll
off the freaking tower himself
let's try the jump
damn i keep missing that
there it is the jumping attack
just gotta hit up and attack at the same
time
there's someone behind me yeah
oh no
i
really you just have so many attacks
nice i really hate how slow this
freaking two-hander is
oh that was one-handed that wasn't even
two-handed jesus
oh there was a bridge there that whole
time why didn't i take the bridge
oh we gotta do this again
okay
don't mind me guys
just uh
okay that was awkward
oh no no no yes she like lights on fire
soon and then she tries to hug you or is
it no no no no
that's some bulls scheizer and it just
keeps following you okay
you can hear it
it sounds like sky worms
okay
oh hello
stop laughing
i never did her audio really sucks this
way
other lantern dude
oh that move takes too long to queue
yeah who's laughing now
oh wait
tricky tricky
jesus
okay we're gonna use this bridge that i
didn't see earlier because i'm obviously
a novice
um but i have this bad feeling that it's
just gonna bring us over to where
we kind of were just now at the pot dude
but
it might not be the worst oh
oh don't mind me am i no stamina
okay
okay
deep breaths
what
that was
an item that was not cool
we don't need that right now all right
two estes down but you still
oh you got a freaking huge sword
who gave him that giant sword oh he just
bludgeoned me look it's like dragging on
the ground that's where it's too big for
you i feel like it's like called a flame
bridge nice flame
give me your give me your flame verge
i'm gonna guess that's what it's called
come on come on give me that no you
give me your weapon well at least you
opened up this
shortcut well it's not really how it
goes i guess so huh because that's the
one you tried to open from the other
side is it not yeah
we still haven't found the bonfire yet
though no but i think that's how you got
to get to it so like that's really close
to where we were at right and we opened
that other door so it's actually not
terrible it's just that i'm not um
kindled or anything anymore
i think these are also bad yep
i saw that coming actually i was like i
was right about to say i think these are
oil barrels
rip nine all right what do you so what
what's the verdict yeah that's uh that's
about
we've actually been playing for two
hours so yeah why don't we um i think we
might be doing more tomorrow so i mean
great there's guys right there i don't
care about myself
that's fine it's only 1800 i lost more
like 4 000 somewhere else that's fine um
but yeah that was kind of an early look
at dark souls there's going to probably
be a lot of people streaming it tomorrow
i think as well as us we'll definitely
be back at it yeah and we got some
preview stuff going up i think there's
definitely some
they definitely have
some boss fights so if you're worried
about spoilers don't watch the boss
fights but we're going to try to do some
armor stuff some weapon stuff that we're
allowed to show
definitely thank you mary for joining me
on the stream for nine rips and also to
the chat yeah thank you guys for joining
us so yeah again that was dark souls 3
on pc that's the final game we'll be
playing this a lot more we have a review
coming up shortly after the embargo well
the review is going to be a while review
takes is probably like another week away
no i think okay so it's interesting just
so everyone knows there's a couple of
embargoes but what's gonna happen is
you're gonna see a lot of people
starting to play the game um like the
whole game not just the the pc embargo
that we have tomorrow which is i think
the first three hours right because the
japanese version actually comes out a
couple weeks before the actual us
version that's right so there will be
people like dark souls streamers whatnot
and even us i think we're gonna get
japanese version so that we can play
through the game um and i think embargo
for the review sometime april like maybe
about a week or four or five days before
the actual games comes out which is i
think the 12th or the 14th i can't
remember this specific day but yeah so
the review is going to be a little while
away but mike who's been playing
non-stop yeah non-stop i think he's
almost done with the game he's going to
start a japanese version i think uh when
we when we can which is tomorrow i think
he's back wednesday or thursday i forget
but yeah stay tuned for that i'll
probably just be his co-pilot you'll be
his co-pilot definitely we'll be back
there'll be a lot more dark souls
coverage in the next few days um and
then in the meantime it sounds like a
lot of you guys are interested in the
weapon arts we have a video showing
every weapons weapon arts in a row
um i will put that in the chat for you
guys it sounds like something
you guys are interested in um but it's
we have a video showing every weapon is
it every weapon or is it just a lot of
them because like i'm sure there's like
right okay so the weapon arts are based
on the weapons like you said so we have
every character with their starting
weapon weapons gotcha okay um and those
are unique to each character
so that's a good video to get you
started at least with what you can
expect to see yeah mike's got some crazy
weapons i don't know when he's allowed
to show some of them but i've seen
someone they're pretty cool so
yeah yeah and i was uh going all magic
and i i plan on continuing that trend
all magic
what about have you thought about going
pyromancer at all because the pyromancer
is supposed to be like a hybrid that
does do magic but then also is like
pretty decent at close range that's
right i went sorcerer because i uh
wanted to go full magic with like the
giant sword and
the daggers and stuff i was trying to be
all distance but the range really harms
you in cases where you need to be close
to the boss which um
there are clearly bosses coming ahead
where
range is not going to help you yeah i
mean sorcery or magic in general i think
is definitely a harder play style to go
through the first time of course because
you know you don't know all the enemy
types how they how they work um you know
what kind of attacks they have and you
don't like it's one of those things
where i feel like you know all the speed
runs like of dark souls one and one now
we're like all magic right because they
they found a way to you know make that
really work and like get the right
spells and whatnot magic of course is a
little bit different here because you
have more stuff to do than just like you
know shooting a soul bowl or whatnot but
um
yeah i credit to you for you know
manning up so to speak and going magic
first because that's definitely
uh that i would think in my mind
definitely a harder route that i
would be too nervous to do well
we'll see yeah i guess it's like
everybody's different play style this is
my first time doing all magic so it's
it's exciting to see what what's ahead
and mike's already told me there's a lot
of wicked bosses um i'm excited to see
what's around the corner so you guys saw
the first three areas mostly like
there's like the starting area the first
boss there's the hub
um
like the wall the
lothric wall
and with that boss um and then now this
is the undead
so that's the very beginning of dark
souls 3. i hope you guys enjoyed this
stream
uh and yeah that's that's it for us
thanks again for watching and we will be
back with more dark souls on gamespot
stay tuned
bye-bye
give me silky silky give me smooth
smooth
you